the Michael Scott foundation is still in
existence there you are
I don't think we have finished with my
inbox what Scots taught has a really
mention years local businessman
Blanche is college tuition to third
graders
[Music]
all right just second everyone I'm sorry
could I have your attention please
thank you haha hi sorry I just have an
announcement to make
okay I have learned a lot about Indian
culture tonight but I have learned even
more about love and I know you're all
thinking who is this crazy gringo and
what is he talking about well I'm not
crazy maybe I'm crazy in love so without
further ado Carol Carol stills I would
like you to do me the honor of making me
your husband Oh Michael what are you
saying can we talk about this in private
I didn't hear you can we talk about this
in private
mr. Scott I know you're a busy man and
your schedule moves around a lot but for
all your generosity through the years
your tots who are ready to graduate
thought it was time to give you a proper
thank you made us realize we don't need
to compromise we have it all this you've
made it possible for us to achieve
improbable
I was late Saturday I have an
announcement to make I am moving to
Costa Rica I thought about it for a long
time now and I'm finally gonna do it
so I'm gonna hop the fence and jog home
so alike
so I like
what are you doing what are you doing
I'm I checked you are what is I didn't
I'd have a ride home
if you sit in the back let's put your
hands together and give a warm welcome
for the man of the hour mr. Michael
Scott I am never going to forget today
not a chance
I don't think I could ever give back to
you what you have given me today who
here's done something stupid in their
lives like skipped out on study hall or
mix up the difference between a gym and
B gym that sort of thing
show of hands anybody yes bunch of you
okay well me too I've done something
stupid which I would like to share
should we go no no we're okay it's a
it's a double period all right I came
here today because I promised you
tuition and tuition is very valuable but
you know what's invaluable is intuition
you know what that is that is the
ability to know when something is about
to happen does anybody out there have
intuition no it's gonna happen next
nobody okay you gonna make me say it all
right I am so proud of all of you Derek
and LaFave and and Ben and Ayana and
Makayla and Nikki and Jason and I'm
sorry okay so we're spacing your name
I'm Zaya
Michaela's younger brother well Sian I
am NOT going to be paying for your
tuition which brings me to my main point
and that is that I will not be able to
pay for anybody's tuition I'm so so
sorry
okay nice everybody enjoying their meal
hey babe
yeah how about we take the beer sign
down until our guests leave and then we
can discuss it
no no I'm gonna leave it up I'm doing it
ties a whole room together
okay Jake thanks hunters very talented
you know what I'm good at least he's an
artist
BFD I'm a screenwriter I'm a maker by Yo
no all you do is you get me to try to
work on my rich friends for an
investment opportunity man I would love
to burn your handles you burn it you buy
it
Oh I'll be your first customer and
you're a Ardley by verse
[Music]
$200 plasma screen TV you just killed
good luck hand me back on your zero
dollars a year salary plus benefits babe
I'm gonna get going
fives get out of here it's good no you
know hold on now I can't pay for your
college but you don't have to go to
class to be in class online courses are
a viable option to a traditional college
experience and the best way to access
those courses is with your own personal
laptop which is rendered useless without
batteries and I have one for each of you
thank you very much our suspect has
straight brown hair she is wearing blue
jeans and a black top so behold our
Bachelorette give her a 10 for looks and
a 3 for her ability to describe herself
hello my lady
Michael aah are you Michael Scott so
Michael what oh I'm sorry I'm I'm
supposed to be meeting someone named
Michael oh that's not yeah Michael
Michael large hot chocolate with caramel
and a shot of peppermint
you